hey youtubers is charlie so Deadpool is
having some fun with Batman V Superman I
thought it was time for a new video
they've released an official synopsis in
the UK and they're saying that the
actual runtime of the UK print of the
movie is going to be longer than in
other places so let's break this down so
here's the actual synopsis for the film
ages it spells out a couple of things
that you probably already picked up from
the trailers but here we go following
his titanic struggle against General Zod
metropolis has been razed to the ground
and Superman is the most controversial
figure in the world well for many he
still is an emblem of Hope a growing
number of people consider him a threat
to humanity seeking justice for the
chaos that he has brought to the earth
as far as Bruce Wayne is concerned
Superman is clearly a danger to society
he fears for the future of the world was
such a reckless power left uncovered so
he dons his mask and cape to write
Superman's wrongs the rivalry between
them is furious fueled by bitterness and
vengeance and nothing can dissuade them
from waging this war however a new dark
threat arises in the form of a third man
one who has a Power greater than either
of them to endanger the world and cause
total destruction so the funny thing
about that synopsis is that it sounds
mysteriously close to Captain America
Civil War one superhero worried about
other powers running around uncovered a
third power rising up that's a danger to
both potentially to be fair Black
Panthers more of a neutral figure than a
danger because he was part of the
Avengers so they'll be teammates
eventually but I just love how like
collectively comic book movies are
shifting the paradigm think back to
Marvel phase one with all the Avengers
first movies like the first Thor movie
the first iron man movie and then the
man of steel movie all about a hero
rising up their big origin story now on
both Marvel and DC sides were in this
post-war period where it's like what are
the people left living in the ashes do
about it like how did they deal with
these superheroes given all the
destruction that's happened you know
even though a bunch of heroes tried to
do good things there's a lot of
collateral damage so in Batman V
Superman that's where Batman puts the
cape back on because it looks like he
put it down after Robin was killed and I
think that's what they're implying by
the trailer but there is a rumor that
Zack Snyder like if you ever watched the
watchman movie they did a fly
cash back to the original Watchmen team
the classic Watchmen team before they
show the modern-day stuff the rumor is
is that Zack Snyder will have a sequence
like that before Batman V Superman where
it shows Batman before he hung up the
cape and cowl now he is going to be in
the Suicide Squad movie so they will
deal with some of the Joker Batman
rivalry but it's a little fuzzy as to
when that happens in the timeline I've
heard that the events of that movie are
supposed to happen before Batman V
Superman and it is kind of an origin
story for Harley Quinn in the Suicide
Squad in general so it makes sense that
they would already exists in the Batman
V Superman world so logically I guess it
would take place before that but
hopefully they'll clarify that after
Batman V Superman comes out with they're
like oh yeah Suicide Squad definitely
happening before Batman V Superman in
the timeline Zack Snyder also had a
couple comments about justice league
only that they're working on it right
now and there's going to be an even
bigger villain he didn't say what the
villains going to be I mean obviously
they're not going to spoil that that
early but odds are if they keep it
terrestrial like if they keep it on
earth they don't include any cosmic
villains like dark side or the new gods
or anybody from apocalypse it'll be
something like Brainiac like if they're
gonna twist the Doomsday origin story
and he's going to be Frankenstein Lex
Luthor's monster then it totally makes
sense that they would have Brainiac
arise from Kryptonian technology that
LuthorCorp tries to use it does sound a
little bit more realistic and they kind
of did something similar in Avengers age
of Ultron you know technically Tony
Stark wasn't immediately responsible for
the creation of Ultron it was really the
mind gem that created Ultron based on a
combination of shitara code along with
Jarvis so I guess I could see a scenario
where Brainiac arises from Kryptonian
technology that loser tries to use and
meld with its own code and it just goes
crazy the problem with Justice League
stories and stories where you use
Superman you use these big godlike
figures is that you have to give them
convincing villains and it does make
sense that they would have trouble
fighting in AI just because you can't
punch an AI out of existence if you
haven't been reading any post convergent
Superman titles they depowered him big
time just to give him some more
relatable problems although technically
he's more like Golden Age power levels
like leap tall buildings in a single
bound Superman but I know a lot of you
guys have been asking about the rumored
review of Batman V Superman that's on
reddit I generally try to avoid stuff
like that in most of the people i know
that heavily
seen older copies of the script say that
there's a lot of stuff in that review
that's nowhere in the movie so is a bit
dubious so take it with a grain of salt
it might be true but I don't think that
it is and the other really big
controversial thing you may have just
heard is that daredevil season 2 might
end up dropping the same weekend is
Batman V Superman that like that same
Friday the movies coming out March 25th
now Netflix are the people that controls
when daredevil season 2 drops they
pretty much finished the season the
probably doing some final touches on it
over the most part daredevil season two
is good to go Marvel does not decide
when that airs Netflix is the one that
owns the series Marvel probably has some
influence when that happens they're
probably like okay we think you should
drop it near captain america civil war
or near these other movies but
ultimately netflix is the one that
decides when daredevil season 2 comes so
the implication is is that it's not that
netflix wants to hurt batman v superman
the movie it's just that they're trying
to be disruptors like hey look we have
this awesome thing that you can watch as
much of as you want anytime and it's all
available right now now March 25th is a
long way off so i have a feeling
somebody in warner brothers office is pi
placing 10 or 15 calls to someone in
netflix is office saying WTF can you
move the premiere date by at least a
week so i'll be super surprised if
daredevil season 2 still ends up
dropping on the same day as Batman V
Superman now they'll definitely overlap
a little bit there's no doubt about that
but I just feel like Netflix would back
off doing something quite so dick is
releasing a giant series on the same day
as another Studios giant tent pole movie
let me know in the comments though do
you actually think that Netflix is still
going to release daredevil season 2 the
same day Batman V Superman comes out or
do you think that they'll move it a
little bit if you remember Batman V
Superman was originally supposed to drop
around the same time captain america
civil war was going to drop but then
Warner Brothers wisely just chose to
avoid that move the movie up to march so
they're they're nowhere near each other
competition is totally healthy but I
actually I think it would hurt both
movies if they were to come out at the
same time because there's always going
to be a bunch of people that only have
money to see one of those movies now of
course me a lot of you guys would
probably go broke trying to see both
movies but there's just like a certain
percentage of the population probably
most people devoto
only have time and money to see one of
those movies so the smart business
decision on both of their parts is to
just space them out a little bit but in
related free news there is a whole bunch
of TV coming at the end of the month so
we have legends of tomorrow arrow the
flash coming back agent Carter season 2
there's even a couple shows dropping
tonight I'm probably not going to do
videos for like shannara chronicles' I
might do a premiere video but be sure to
subscribe to get everything and I do
have some new Star Wars and some new
legends of tomorrow I don't know which
order those videos are going to post you
can follow me on Twitter and Facebook
for updates on that stuff so why you
guys wait for everything to finish
posting you can click here for all my
Batman V Superman videos and you can
click here for my Deadpool video from
last night thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight